let's go next to aaron from california
erin you're on the air
aaron from california you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
hey awesome well my question is kind of
like
a bit more broad i guess because so
after obviously i mean we can all agree
like
the last two three months has been like
an insane amount of like just
pure disinformation from the republican
party
yeah across the board so i'm wondering
obviously this is kind of a long shot
but like would it be possible for like a
type of regulation
that we kind of say like hey like
all x types of like new upcoming social
media companies are established
to have like either like a chief
scientific officer
or like some type of panel on these
companies that goes through like
what's in the media what's being what's
being spoken about and reported and see
like
what is the obvious types of
disinformation that like these companies
can try
and stop no i don't see any shot at that
whatsoever i don't think there's any
legal basis for it and i also don't
think it's the right way to fight
disinformation i've said this before
in different formats or with different
framings and i'll say it again
the solution to disinformation
conspiracy theories
anti-science anti-vaxx delusional q anon
fox news oan newsmax rush limbaugh mark
levin alex jones to all that stuff
the solution is uh better educated
people
teaching media literacy early creating a
culture where people
have a healthy skepticism when they are
given information by something that
maybe the news or maybe just looks like
news i don't think that we i i just
i don't believe and i've seen no
evidence that we can
regulate our way out of the
disinformation ignorance crisis
yeah yeah for sure i mean like because i
think the big thing is like
i mean we've seen like just everything
escalate in terms of disinformation
so so exponentially over the last few
years
that it feels like at least to me but i
don't know like obviously yeah we could
i definitely agree with the route of
like educating the populace over time
but it feels like there's so many people
that it would take so long it would that
here's the thing here's the thing
it took ford i've been i've been
repeating this a lot because it's
important to understand
it took 40 years for things to get this
bad
it's going to take a long time to fix it
and and we have to be okay with that we
just have to improve because
the only way you you quickly change
something as big as what you're talking
about is via dictatorship and we don't
want to be a dictatorship
and so i think we just have to concede
it's going to take a while to fix this
and that's
it it's not that it's okay we'd rather
fix it more quickly
but we don't really have a choice in a
democracy
yeah of course all right well thank you
david
i appreciate it thank you so much uh
there is uh
another perfect phone call for lack of a
better term
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford
i asked them to be a sponsor because
they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout